miles de pruebas de kobe 19 se toman a
diario en eeuu y ahora los científicos
en california analizan estas muestras
para determinar si la nueva cepa del
virus identificada en reino unido- ya
llegó al país canadá suecia a francia y
españa- se sumaron a la lista de países
que en los últimos días han detectado en
sus territorios esta variante que es
hasta un 70% más infecciosa no olvidemos
que los casos que se detectan de la cepa
británica son casos que entran por el
aeropuerto madrid-barajas a veces aún no
tiene que hacer memoria y pensar que
nosotros llevamos desde hace seis meses
llevamos seis meses pidiendo la
importancia como se ha comprobado ahora
del control en nuestro aeropuerto desde
que las autoridades británicas
informaron sobre la situación la lista
de países que han restringido los vuelos
desde reino unido van en aumento
japón que recientemente descubrió sus
primeros casos de esta variante ordenó
la prohibición del ingreso de ciudadanos
extranjeros no residentes desde el 28 de
diciembre y hasta finales de enero
mientras que filipinas que no registra
contagiados por esta nueva cepa
extendió la restricción de vuelos
provenientes del reino unido hasta
mitades de enero y aunque han surgido
dudas sobre si esta nueva cepa planteará
nuevos desafíos para los científicos
las farmacéuticas modernas cure bach
astrazéneca y beyoncé dijeron que
esperan que sus vacunas sigan siendo
efectivas